[Music]
good morning guys
and I had an addiction I was addicted I
was an alcoholic and used drugs
[Music]
and one day when I was drunk I said goodbye
sir I read if really as people say
[Music]
that he had  you take away all these addictions
that if in reality you are like that
take away this addiction of alcohol and
drugs
you know that we take my family
I want my family I do not want to lose
my wife I do not want my children
tomorrow to be like this
help me
and it was when God  changed my life
[Music]
in a part of the bible it says that he
commanded moses to take us out of the land
of egypt to take us to the promised land
to the land where milk and honey flows
[Music]
so in our moments we are in
this land  because this land flows
all that
[Music]
or it is planted here thanks to the colorado river
[Applause]
[Music]
d
de colorado river is the life of yuma
we live with a jobs in  my case of
colorado r  iver
the vice of information will give from colorado
river to open the lethal lists world
will grace jones we got to be there be
more active guagua comerme el de vodka
vieneses to be good managers woods words
of the resources del gb
already with me this morning
I'm going to start  to be a good
administrator
say with me I will be a good administrator
of the blessings that God has given me
meunier the members of art search yuma
the walking of agriculture
famous photo rich demands mail da show
drinks facebook project
[Music]
exists if your trip says of  hard work in
people
most of the population and human of the
americas
[Music]
today we live in san luís rio colorado
sonora
in 1990 we came here to
arizona now he drives a tractor I do
the borders the canals tell them
to pour water for  water the height
[Music]
and the people are very noble the people are very
good no it's no it's bad people
in this town we are very calm
we live well right
now  we are living a good life
[Music]
let's not wait on god that everything turns out everything
stays the same
[Music]
sing
and
to skate well and the look of
liszt
is that Mario
[Music]
on
the machine
and  it looks difficult it
's
one
of
[Music]
they
tenth and a half of an ax
efe singer
happy alarm
[Music]
psystar working for five
and
yes
or
lópez to the channel
help light and that's
the sound of my
love
granma de la  berlinale was pressing
when carlos
náder woke him up and haywoode
workman
javier durán shot and in his face the
reigning goal in this fresh
[Music]
because it is a very heavy job
but very beautiful
because it fills us with satisfaction
that we can  work
to be able to send this food to other parts of the
world
father at this time sir we
thank you sir virtues allowed to reach
these moments
[Music]
amen and let's give it
I have five children four men and
girls and they are all studying
[Music]
field workers for many years and
from there our children were taught to
work on the land
they went to work with us and they
knew that the effort their
parents made was to help them
work in the fields  It's beautiful, it's dignified,
but we've always told
you, you go further,
so what more can you ask of
life and goodbye
[Music]
we have everything
Christian hours debates in the presence
of the live new beginning
the patina of color to the  strong river that
represents we are side
disconnect from world cup gables
[Music]
this morning I want to tell you to be
careful
and take care of what God has given us
we live in a city blessed by God
if we do not take care of our
heritage we are losing our river  Leaving our
grandchildren
very beneficial
says that it is not very great of
hard-working good
and supports many families
to many families
the reported
because life goes
water is life
[Music]
jesus entered the waters
and sanctified the waters
jesus enters our hearts
santi invites into our hearts
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
his life
yes
[Music]